This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. We get messages all the time from listeners who say the show has helped them think differently about the world and about themselves. As producers, nothing is more rewarding or gratifying. A while back, we heard a listener story that especially moved us. Hello, Shankar and Hidden Brain team. My name is Audrey Hombren. The point of this message is to send you a huge thank you as your show is the leading reason for one
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们经常收到听众的来信，他们说这个节目帮助他们以不同的方式思考世界和自己。作为制作人，没有什么比这更令人欣慰或满足的了。前段时间，我们听到一个特别打动我们的听众故事。你好，尚卡尔和《Hidden Brain》团队。我叫奥黛丽·洪布伦。写这封信的目的是向你们表达巨大的感谢，因为你们的节目是我做出人生中最重大决定之一的主要原因。
of the biggest decisions of my life. Today we tell you what happened. It's a tale about two friends and how our show played a small role in their dramatic story. We begin with a young man named Alex Eastman. Growing up in Colorado Springs, Alex was obsessed with sports and exercise. So when I was in high school, nothing really stopped me. I mean, I played sports all through high school. I was a year-round player. I did a baseball wrestling and I played football. But I mean, even outside of those sports,
今天我们来告诉大家发生了什么。这是一个关于两个朋友的故事，以及我们的节目如何在他们戏剧性的故事中发挥了微小的作用。我们从一个叫亚历克斯·伊斯特曼的年轻人说起。亚历克斯在科罗拉多斯普林斯长大，痴迷于运动和锻炼。所以当我在高中时，没有什么能真正阻止我。我的意思是，我整个高中都在参加体育运动。我是一个全年无休的运动员。我打棒球、摔跤，还踢足球。但我的意思是，即使在这些运动之外，
I was consistently, you know, at the gym with all my friends who are in high school playing basketball or working out, going on hikes. But something happened in the summer of 2011 when Alex was 18. The biggest time that I finally hit me that something was wrong was when I was camping with my family out in John Martin, reservoir here in Colorado.
我总是和朋友们在健身房打篮球、锻炼或去徒步旅行。但在2011年夏天，当亚历克斯18岁时，发生了一件事。我最终意识到出大事了，那是在我和家人在科罗拉多州的约翰·马丁水库露营的时候。
And it was like a hundred degrees outside, and I started feeling ill, and my grandparents had a camper, so I ended up going into the camper and passing out in their bed. Like wrapped up in the blankets, because I thought it was so cold. Then I drenched the bed and sweat.
外面有100华氏度（约38摄氏度），我开始感到不舒服。我祖父母有一辆露营车，所以我最后进了露营车，在他们的床上昏了过去。我裹着毯子，因为我觉得太冷了。然后我浑身是汗，把床都浸透了。
So my parents at that point were like, yeah, no, we need to take him to the hospital. His parents rushed him to an emergency room in Colorado Springs, where he was diagnosed with pneumonia. But after a few days of the hospital, it became clear that something else was wrong. And towards the last day of recovery, I went to the restroom and ended up urinating
所以我父母当时就说，不行，我们得带他去医院。他的父母把他送到了科罗拉多斯普林斯的急诊室，在那里他被诊断出患有肺炎。但在医院住了几天后，很明显还有别的问题。在康复的最后一天，我去了洗手间，结果尿出了
blood. I didn't know what to think about it. And when I told the nurse, she was like, oh, yeah, let me go get the doctor because that is not good. And then the doctor was like, okay, well, we need to do an ultrasound on your kidneys now. The doctor came in and then that's when he told me that I had dense deposit disease. And he started telling us like how rare the disease is. We kind of paused in silence because none of us knew what this was. Dense deposit disease, also known as C3G, happens when your body's own immune system attacks the kidneys. Over time, your kidneys
血。我不知道该怎么想。当我告诉护士时，她说，哦，是的，让我去叫医生，因为这可不好。然后医生说，好吧，我们现在需要给你的肾脏做超声波检查。医生进来后，告诉我有致密沉积物病。他开始告诉我们这种病有多罕见。我们陷入了沉默，因为我们谁都不知道这是什么。致密沉积物病，也称为C3G，发生在身体自身的免疫系统攻击肾脏时。随着时间的推移，你的肾脏
become unable to remove waste products and extra fluid from the blood. Eventually, it can cause total kidney failure. I didn't know what it meant to me or what it was going to do to me, but it did change my life. At first, I didn't encounter any crazy problems health-wise, other than the underlying condition, which never really inhibited my day in any shorter way. In the fall of 2013, two years after that day in the hospital, Alex was living a busy life.
变得无法从血液中清除废物和多余的液体。最终，它会导致肾功能完全衰竭。我不知道这对意味着什么，也不知道它会对我做什么，但它确实改变了我的生活。起初，除了潜在的疾病外，我没有遇到任何严重的健康问题，这种疾病从未真正以任何方式阻碍我的日常生活。2013年秋天，也就是在医院那天的两年后，亚历克斯过着忙碌的生活。
He was in a sophomore year in college, studying human biology, and had just started working at a restaurant in Colorado Springs called Old Chicago. That's where he met a young woman named Audrey Humbren. I was working downstairs serving while she was upstairs bartending. There was like nights we would close together, so we were both there until, you know, 2 to 33 o'clock in the morning, like helping each other clean up, what needs to be cleaned, rolling silverware,
他当时是大二学生，学习人类生物学，刚开始在科罗拉多斯普林斯一家叫“老芝加哥”的餐厅工作。就在那里，他遇到了一个叫奥黛丽·洪布伦的年轻女子。我在楼下做服务员，而她在楼上做调酒师。我们经常一起下班，所以我们俩一直待到凌晨2点到3点，互相帮忙打扫卫生，卷餐具，
talking about the night. They became friends and started hanging out. The long hours and grueling work brought them close. It's almost like family, because you guys have a sitting there, getting your butts kicked the whole time, but you're also helping each other with everything. And you don't ever ask questions, you just kind of do. In 2014, after working at Oleshikago for about a year, Alex's doctor told him that even though he was still healthy, it was time to go on the waiting list for a kidney transplant. For many people with dense deposit disease, complete kidney failure happens within 10 years,
聊聊当晚的事。他们成了朋友，开始一起出去玩。漫长的工时和繁重的工作让他们变得亲密。这几乎就像家人一样，因为你们坐在那里，一直被生活折磨，但你们也在互相帮助。你从不问为什么，只是去做。2014年，在“老芝加哥”工作了大约一年后，亚历克斯的医生告诉他，尽管他身体仍然健康，但该去肾移植等待名单上排队了。对于许多患有致密沉积物病的人来说，肾功能完全衰竭会在10年内发生，
so Alex didn't have a lot of time. The biggest hurdle was finding a donor who would be a match. Blood type is the biggest thing. Having someone with the same blood type helps a lot more to help you get that kidney quicker. At work, Alex mostly kept his condition to himself. But later that year, he helped to organize a fundraiser for the National Kidney Foundation. Audrey was working the bar and at the end of the night, she asked him why he cared so much about kidney disease. That's when he told her what he was going through.
所以亚历克斯没有多少时间了。最大的障碍是找到匹配的捐赠者。血型是最重要的。拥有相同血型的人能更有助于更快地获得肾脏。在工作中，亚历克斯大多对自己的病情保密。但那年晚些时候，他帮忙组织了一场为国家肾脏基金会的筹款活动。奥黛丽在吧台工作，那天晚上结束时，她问他为什么这么关心肾脏疾病。那时他才告诉她他正在经历的事情。
You know, I'm on the transplant list. I don't know when I'm going to get one. She was just kind of like, oh, like, you know, I'm sorry you have to do that. Music Years passed. Alex's life was pretty normal, aside from taking about eight pills every day, to keep his condition under control. He was still working at Olshikago, still hanging out with Audrey and her friends, still playing softball and lifting weights. In 2016, he graduated from college. I was a pretty active person, even with having this disease that no one even really knew that I had. But by 2018, seven years after his diagnosis, his energy started to plummet, and his relationships started to suffer.
你知道，我在移植名单上。我不知道什么时候能等到一个。她只是说，哦，你知道，我很抱歉你必须经历这些。音乐。几年过去了。亚历克斯的生活相当正常，除了每天服用大约八种药来控制病情。他仍然在“老芝加哥”工作，仍然和奥黛丽及她的朋友们一起玩，仍然打垒球和举重。2016年，他大学毕业了。我是一个相当活跃的人，即使患有这种没人知道我有的疾病。但到了2018年，也就是确诊七年后，他的精力开始急剧下降，他的人际关系也开始受到影响。
He remembers one day that summer when his girlfriend wanted to plan something special for him when he got home from work. A date night. And she was talking to me all day about, hey, let's make dinner or like help me plan something. And I was like, can we see how I feel when I get off of work? Or on 7 o'clock, Alex got home. And I just wasn't in the mood for it. I mean, Alex got home. And I just wasn't in the mood for it.
他记得那年夏天的一天，当他下班回家时，他的女朋友想为他计划一些特别的事情。一个约会之夜。她整天都在跟我说，嘿，我们做顿晚餐或者帮我计划点什么。我说，能不能等我下班看我感觉如何再说？或者在7点钟，亚历克斯到家了。我只是没心情。我的意思是，亚历克斯到家了。我只是没心情。
I mean, just wanted to sleep. I mean, she tried to like surprise me with getting everything for dinner and I just being so tired, eating did not sound great to me at all. It did, unfortunately, become an everyday thing that I just got home and most of the time I didn't want to move. In December of that year, 2018, Audrey invited Alex to her 30th birthday party at a dance hall. At that point, he was on dialysis and going almost every other day. But he didn't
我的意思是，我只想睡觉。她试图给我惊喜，准备了晚餐，但我太累了，吃东西对我来说一点也不吸引人。不幸的是，这成了每天的常态，我回到家，大多数时候我都不想动。那年12月，2018年，奥黛丽邀请亚历克斯参加她在舞厅举办的30岁生日派对。那时，他正在进行透析，几乎每隔一天就要去一次。但他不想
want to miss Audrey's birthday, so he decided to go. When Alex walked into the party that night, Audrey and her husband looked at him with alarm. And they were like, you just don't look good, you don't look like yourself anymore. I would say I was looking really tired and pale like I lost a lot of color in my skin. Alex confessed that his condition was getting worse. He wasn't feeling well, and pretty soon he'd be spending even more time in dialysis. He had to find a kidney donor and according to his doctor, he had to find one soon. Audrey asked herself whether she would be willing to donate a kidney to Alex.
错过奥黛丽的生日，所以他决定去。那天晚上亚历克斯走进派对时，奥黛丽和她的丈夫惊恐地看着他。他们说，你看上去不太好，你看起来不像你自己了。我会说我看起来真的很累，脸色苍白，好像皮肤失去了很多血色。亚历克斯承认他的病情正在恶化。他感觉不好，很快他就要花更多时间在透析上。他必须找到一个肾脏捐赠者，根据医生的说法，他必须尽快找到一个。奥黛丽问自己是否愿意给亚历克斯捐献一个肾脏。
But she knew his blood type was positive and hers was AB. She wasn't a match. Some kidney donations can take place between donors of different blood types, but patients with type O blood typically need donors who are also type O. A donation between them would never work. As the months passed, Alex's health continued to decline. It was a tough time, yeah, it was. From what I remember, it was a very, you know, I didn't leave the house. I mean, you don't realize, I guess, what I'm saying is you don't realize how much the
但她知道他的血型是O型阳性，而她是AB型。她不匹配。有些肾脏捐赠可以在不同血型的捐赠者之间进行，但O型血的患者通常需要同样是O型的捐赠者。他们之间的捐赠永远行不通。随着几个月过去，亚历克斯的健康状况持续恶化。那是一段艰难的时光，是的。据我记得，那是非常，你知道，我没有离开过家。我的意思是，你没有意识到，我想说的是，你没有意识到
kidney does for you until yours doesn't work anymore. Alex was at a low point. But his luck was about to change. One morning in March of 2019, Alex was in dialysis when his phone started to buzz. It was Audrey. And I just remember kind of like
肾脏对你有多重要，直到你的肾脏不再工作。亚历克斯处于低谷。但他的运气即将改变。2019年3月的一个早晨，亚历克斯正在透析时，他的手机开始震动。是奥黛丽打来的。我只记得当时
half asleep waking up looking at it saying, oh, hey Alex, like I just finished kind of like half asleep waking up looking at it saying, oh, hey, Alex, like I just finished listening to this podcast. It's from Hidden Brain, like you should go listen to it. They discuss the whole kidney exchange program and like how that, even if she isn't my blood type, she can help me renew my life and not be sitting in the chair that I was in. And it just kind of snowballed from there. [♪ Music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background I'm Shankar Vedantam and you're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Before the break, we met a young man named Alex Eastman.
半睡半醒地看着手机，说，哦，嘿亚历克斯，我刚听完这个播客。是《Hidden Brain》的，你应该去听听。他们讨论了整个肾脏交换计划，以及即使她不是我的血型，她也可以帮助我重获新生，而不是坐在我当时坐的那把椅子上。事情就这样像滚雪球一样发展起来了。[背景音乐] 我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，你正在收听《Hidden Brain》。休息之前，我们认识了一位叫亚历克斯·伊斯特曼的年轻人。
He told us about his struggle with dense deposit disease, which was slowly destroying his kidneys and eroding his quality of life. When we left off, Alex had already spent almost five years on the transplant list, waiting for someone with the same blood type to donate a kidney to him. He was on dialysis three days a week, and at the age of 26, it seemed like his life was ending. His doctor told him he didn't have much time. His friend Audrey briefly asked herself if she wanted to donate a kidney to him, but her blood type was in the match. She
他告诉我们他与致密沉积物病的斗争，这种病正在慢慢摧毁他的肾脏并侵蚀他的生活质量。当我们离开时，亚历克斯已经在移植名单上待了近五年，等待着血型相同的人为他捐献肾脏。他每周进行三次透析，在26岁时，他的生命似乎走到了尽头。他的医生告诉他，他没有多少时间了。他的朋友奥黛丽曾短暂地问过自己是否想给他捐献一个肾脏，但她的血型不匹配。她
was type AB, he was type O. And then in March of 2019, Audrey heard an episode of Hidden Brain. I was listening to the Hidden Brain episode for Sale by Owner and Al Roth was speaking about the paired exchange program. The paired exchange program is a novel way to donate kidneys, thought up by the economist Al Roth and his colleagues. In traditional kidney exchange, donors have to be carefully matched to recipients with compatible blood types and other factors. But by applying the insights of Game Theory, Al Roth realized that a donor did not need to have a compatible blood type with their intended recipient. I could donate an organ to your loved one, and you could donate an organ to mine. As soon as Audrey heard about this idea in our episode, she sent a text to Alex.
是AB型，他是O型。然后在2019年3月，奥黛丽听了一集《Hidden Brain》。我当时正在听《Hidden Brain》关于“业主出售”的那一集，阿尔·罗斯正在谈论配对交换计划。配对交换计划是一种捐献肾脏的新颖方式，由经济学家阿尔·罗斯和他的同事构思。在传统的肾脏交换中，捐赠者必须与血型兼容的接受者仔细匹配。但通过应用博弈论的见解，阿尔·罗斯意识到捐赠者不需要与预期的接受者有兼容的血型。我可以给你的爱人捐献一个器官，而你可以给我的爱人捐献一个。奥黛丽在我们的节目中听到这个想法后，立刻给亚历克斯发了一条短信。
And I said, hey, do you know what kidney exchange is? And he texted back and he said, yes, I know what this is, but nobody is really willing to do it for me because they don't like the idea that their kidney is not going directly to me. And I messaged him back and I said, well that's ridiculous. Why haven't you told me about this? Where do I go to to sign up to see about doing this? So he sent me the link. So I looked it up and I immediately started doing the application and halfway down the application, it definitely asks for your blood type. And I could not remember if it was a B positive
我说，嘿，你知道什么是肾脏交换吗？他回短信说，是的，我知道这是什么，但没有人愿意为我做，因为他们不喜欢他们的肾脏不能直接给我的想法。我回信说，那太荒谬了。你为什么没告诉我这个？我去哪里报名参加这个？所以他发给了我链接。我查了一下，立刻开始申请，申请进行到一半时，它确实要求填写血型。我记不清是AB型阳性
or a B negative. Audrey went upstairs to her office where her husband, Zabab was playing video games. She walked over to the filing cabinet where they kept their medical records and pulled out the folder with her blood type in it. A little piece of paper, the size of a credit card, fell to the floor. And we pick up the card because it fell face down. And we flipped it over and it said O positive.
还是AB型阴性。奥黛丽走到楼上的办公室，她的丈夫扎巴布正在玩电子游戏。她走到他们存放医疗记录的文件柜前，拿出了装有她血型的文件夹。一张信用卡大小的小纸片掉到了地板上。我们捡起那张卡片，因为它正面朝下。我们把它翻过来，上面写着O型阳性。
O positive, just like Alex. A few months earlier when she had considered donating an organ to her friend Audrey had misremembered her blood type. She was in fact a perfect match. Alex would not have to wait for the paired exchange program to get a viable organ, she could directly give him her kidney. We could hear the angels, like, oh, so I started crying because that's just who I am. I am an emotional human. So and I immediately text Alex and I say Alex. I know I just text you about doing the paired exchange, but I am a match. And so we both, we both were texting X-Wit-S-3-J-W-N-I-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-W-3-J-W-N-Y way you're kidding you're joking what is happening?
O型阳性，和亚历克斯一样。几个月前，当她考虑给朋友捐献器官时，奥黛丽记错了自己的血型。事实上，她是一个完美的匹配。亚历克斯不必等待配对交换计划来获得可用的器官，她可以直接给他捐献肾脏。我们可以听到天使的声音，哦，所以我开始哭，因为我就是这样的人。我是一个感性的人。所以我立刻给亚历克斯发短信说，亚历克斯。我知道我刚给你发短信说要做配对交换，但我是一个匹配者。所以我们俩都在发短信……天哪，你在开玩笑吗？发生了什么？
And so I exit out of that application on my computer and I open up the application to be a donor and within a month we got a surgery scheduled I remember it was really early and the sun was just coming up and I remember we were walking into the hospital and the sunrise was just so beautiful. I remember that the morning itself was very quiet so walking into the hospital. There's not a lot of people there yet. The hustle and bustle hasn't started. There was a lot of peace in that moment.
所以我退出了电脑上的那个申请，打开了作为捐赠者的申请，一个月内我们就安排好了手术。我记得那天很早，太阳刚刚升起，我记得我们走进医院，日出真是太美了。我记得那天早上非常安静，走进医院时，还没有多少人。喧嚣还没有开始。那一刻有一种宁静。
Waiting to be called back. I believe Audrey got called back first and she went back and then I was shortly right after her and they ended up actually seating us right next to each other in like the pre-surgery waiting room. right next to each other and like the pre-surgery waiting room. And as they were putting in the IV and they're setting me up, checking my vitals, all that, that's when the emotions really started because it became real in that moment.
等待被叫进去。我相信奥黛丽先被叫进去，她进去了，然后我紧随其后，他们最后实际上把我们安排在手术前的候诊室里，就在彼此旁边。就在彼此旁边，在手术前的候诊室里。当他们给我插上静脉注射，设置好设备，检查我的生命体征时，情绪真的开始了，因为那一刻一切都变得真实了。
When the needle of the IV went into my arm, I was like, oh, okay, we're doing this. This is what we're doing. We're actually, I'm donating a kidney today. And then I just remember Audrey going back and then my mom's over there hugging her. And that is when I just broke down. I was like, ah, and I just start weeping. I was like, oh my god, I'm doing this. And we're just crying in each other's arms before the surgery. And she just simply says, thank you. For everyone's just getting really emotional about what's going on. And then shortly after her, I was right up behind her going to my surgery room. And I was like, oh, this is the day.
当静脉注射的针头扎进我的手臂时，我想，哦，好吧，我们正在做这件事。这就是我们正在做的。我今天真的要捐献一个肾脏。然后我只记得奥黛丽进去了，我妈妈在那边拥抱她。就在那时，我崩溃了。我当时想，啊，我开始哭泣。我当时想，天哪，我正在做这件事。手术前我们在彼此的怀里哭泣。她只是简单地说，谢谢。每个人都对正在发生的事情感到非常激动。不久之后，我就紧随其后进入了手术室。我当时想，哦，就是今天。
And finally, you know, live my life back to pretty much how it was before all this. I remember waking up and like kind of seeing on my family there. Alex knew something was different right away because for the first time in about five years, he didn't feel cold anymore. Instantly that's when I felt it. And even like my parents kind of noticed it. They're like, wow, you're actually like hot right now. And I was like, yeah. And then from there, they said that my color was already
终于，你知道，我的生活恢复到了这一切发生之前的样子。我记得醒来时，看到我的家人都在那里。亚历克斯立刻知道有些不同了，因为在大约五年里，他第一次不再感到寒冷。那一刻我立刻感觉到了。甚至我的父母也注意到了。他们说，哇，你现在真的很热。我说，是的。从那时起，他们说我的脸色已经
coming back. And that I just overall looked better than what I was looking six hours ago before surgery. It wasn't until I got out of the hospital that I really started to notice it because my energy was just above and beyond what it used to be. I overall just feel normal.
恢复了。而且我整体看起来比手术前六个小时好多了。直到我出院后，我才真正注意到这一点，因为我的精力远超从前。我整体感觉很正常。
Like everything that wasn't there, post surgery is right back to where it used to be. that wasn't there post-surgery is right back to where it used to be. It's kind of turned us from friends to family. He and his family have just wrapped their arms around us. We are one of their kids at this point. I consider Alex part of my family. Now like we were good friends before, but our friendship grew a thousand times. I could just never be thankful enough. There are lots of reasons we love to make Hidden Brain for you. Stories like this one are close to the top of the list.
就像手术后所有缺失的东西都回到了原来的位置。手术后所有缺失的东西都回到了原来的位置。这让我们从朋友变成了家人。他和他的家人已经把我们拥入怀中。此时此刻，我们是他们的孩子之一。我把亚历克斯视为我家人的一部分。现在，我们之前是好朋友，但我们的友谊增长了一千倍。我永远感激不尽。我们喜欢为你制作《Hidden Brain》有很多原因。像这样的故事在名单上名列前茅。
We're grateful you've allowed us to play a small role in your life. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Kristen Wong, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If this episode spoke to you, if our show is meaningful to you, please consider supporting us. Go to hiddenbrain.org and click on support. Again, that's hiddenbrain.org and click on support. Thanks for listening. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们很感激你让我们在你的生活中发挥了微小的作用。《Hidden Brain》由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、克里斯汀·王、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《Hidden Brain》的执行编辑。如果这一集触动了你，如果我们的节目对你有意义，请考虑支持我们。前往hiddenbrain.org并点击支持。再说一遍，是hiddenbrain.org并点击支持。感谢收听。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。